All right. So let's look at some basic.
are
syntax
and they will look at some examples with plotting and
the good thing about our studio is
I obviously want to work with data sets.
So some data sets are already included so you don't have to actually go
and create a sample Excel sheet to experiment.
a number of
built-in functions
in our studio
Where you don't have to like?
You can visualize you can visualize.
And work with these important.
Probability distribution functions. So for example then for
discrete.
discreet RVs RV means
random variable
You have popular.
probability distributions like
the binomial distribution
I'll show the function for that.
You have the Plus or the Bernoulli distribution?
Okay, this one has to do with trials.
if you remember I said
trials are special type of experiments. These are
experiments that have
only two possible outcomes like flipping
a coin
There is it to work with and then you have something like the Apostle
distribution.
He then have continuous random variables.
And I told the most important of them all.
whether the discreet or otherwise
Is the normal distribution we'll look at some examples with
this.
But then you also have other ones like the
exponential distribution.
and for
with our studio
you also have
so these are the probability distributions you have different probability distribution
functions to work with these different types of
probability distributions.
And I'll show you some of the steps for that. There's so many examples of
these online.
But we'll go through some of them together.
and the thing with the
the
so our study is great in that it's easy to work with it.
And you don't have to do calculations by
hand. The problem is the
the wave they've done name their function is not really
intuitive. So you you will find yourself.
You have to there's two ways. You can go about working to our
studio either. You always have the documentation.
Website open I'll show you that now to
you or you should find some boilerplate script.
and
refer to that bully boilerplate script every time you want to do
your statistical study.
continuous RVs in the published equations
all three
I mean all all random variables and it
probably should distributions will have
the three types of functions I told you about or two they will
have a
a pmf a pmf and
see the f
if they are discrete.
and if they are continuous they will have
PDF and CDF. So CDF is for both.
Okay.
so
Now, let me take you to documentation website.
So it's this is the website you want to look at and I would
suggest if you're learning our studio use this
website as opposed to.
Going on different blocks.
because the thing with blogs is that it's
a some of them don't use the best.
You know.
functions to do the
study and
and somebody do a better job.
It's a hit and miss kind of situation the so and
I really like the way the document their code. So for example
for the normal distribution
Probability distribution the normal distribution is kind of probably distribution. There
are four kinds of probability distribution
functions.
This is by the way, please put I want
you to look here. This is why this is why at
the beginning I told you I'm very
keen on using precise terms. Yeah, and
I keep going on and on.
with acronyms and their correct
Names, look how our studio just
calls the debt probably density function density.
They don't say that they don't say probably density function.
The desert density then you have distribution function which distribution
function the probability that mass function
or the probability or the cumulative
distribution function. This is why I meant this is what I what I
met when I say it can be confusing.
There are two types there is cmf.
A CDF and pmf and if
we don't like spill out the name completely.
The person on the other end doesn't know to which you're referring and this can
be confusing not to mention.
That the names have given their functions is not really like I
said intuitive.
So you have you will find yourself coming back and forth.
to these
examples and these are standard these are like the
these are Snippets that are used all the time.
Imagine after having to work with the more novel.
function
function so they have they have the PDF.
They have the pmf.
and the cmf